and so like I I just feel like you
should you know wait for that okay
because because if she's treating you
like an option you are and she's
probably talking to like 10 other D like
stop it how do you think that the world
of because here's here's something
that's interesting because
with you're in your mid-20s right so
you've grown up in an era where
smartphones and social media yeah have
always been there during those formative
years in your you know teens pre-teens
to teens and so on I got mine in eighth
grade in eighth grade yeah so so this is
something that's interesting because by
the time the smartphone and social media
came out in my case I was already in my
in my in my 20s so there was an era
before that even free internet and free
email and all that and so I think even
with a 10-year age Gap say between
someone who's 35 and 25 or 32 and 22
there's actually because of the
technology there's quite a there can be
quite a Chasm because when when I was in
school there was no smartphones there
were no there was no social media none
of that stuff existed even the internet
was very much in its infancy we had dial
up first of all and it was very slow
when I was in school it took um I mean
to download a song it took like you know
if you wanted to download an album back
when people using Napster you left it to
run overnight I've never even heard an
app store yeah you'd never I don't even
know what that is there we go right
General generation gap it's a
peer-to-peer music sharing site uh this
one people you know started downloading
and stuff I mean do you know what a CD
is yeah okay
I've actually met people who died I'm
like oh my gosh man am I in boom right
now
okay my sister yeah okay
so that that's been that's so
interesting to me because I I can't
really if I think back to when I was in
school whether in Saudi Arabia or in the
UK and boarding school if I think of
adding smartphones and social media on
top of all that teenage stuff already
going on it just sounds like a
it sounds like an absolute nightmare but
I think that it's it's interesting
because people who are now in their 20s
a lot of stuff that is just normal to
them and standard and I I don't think
they are really thinking that oh you
know there was a whole era yeah before
this before Instagram and Snapchat and
you know YouTube and Tick Tock and all
these things that it's so new yeah it's
so new so how what kind of impact do you
think that that's had on the
perspectives of both men young men and
women who are growing up now and who are
who are coming up and experiencing all
this
um I think that it gasses up girls egos
okay yeah I think that Instagram is like
a toxic
app I mean it can be you can't I will
say social media has changed my life for
the better I I get to do I love this job
I would I am so happy now like I this is
so fun and it's I I am good like but I
would say overall as a society it's like
been worse and I I think like girls like
we think we're hotter than we are
because yeah like yeah and I noticed
this partially at the pickup boot camp
so I'm like you're rejecting him and I
was like I wonder if I
and I was like
um yeah but like I because you can get
like crazy DMS from people and girls
think that these guys are actually
trying to like wifer I have brothers so
like they would humble me you know what
I mean shout out shout out Austin shout
out Adam
um but like yeah I feel like Instagram
just like gasses up girls Egos and it
makes men like more lonely I guess
um yeah you're absolutely right I mean I
think one thing that techno Technology's
done a lot but in terms of the the
dating market and those Dynamics one
thing it's man it's done a lot one thing
it's done from the female perspective
you've already touched on this is if you
think back to even like the most
beautiful girl in a town or a village in
a city or in the past right
it was she only had access to the men in
her locality right so the the most
beautiful girl in a school or a college
or whatever there was still this limited
pool so she might get gassed up or you
know it could be even an average coach
it doesn't need to be beautiful but I
think that you're you're getting
attention from the males in your local
vicinity whereas now
a girl can be hot and have tens hundreds
of thousands millions of potential
interested males expressing interest in
giving daily validation yeah from the
entire world right there could be good
dudes in Africa Asia the middle east
Europe USA wherever right and there's
just and guys are so thirsty online
right the guys are just there messing up
the game online but I just with their
insane thirst and
and it's just all there so it's like wow
how can how can this woman not have yeah
like of course of course she has it this
is why we got to bring back bullying
yeah yeah tell me more I I feel like
okay I feel like everyone should have a
healthy amount of bullying growing up
agreed because because no because I and
I think that's why people from bigger
families are better than everyone else
because because if I started to think
too highly of myself my older brother
would would humble me yes he would tell
me now you're ugly and
maybe like I'll be like oh this guy
messaged me yeah okay
Savage yeah shout out Austin
and I'm like I just feel like it grounds
you a little bit and it doesn't you
don't get that big of an ego because
like the people around you won't let you
but now we're afraid to be humble and
nobody can be made fun of yes and that's
what I don't like that's why when they
were making me get in trouble for over
my whale comments I'm like whales can be
made fun of just like everyone else if
you want to make fun of me for being a
ginger I'll take I'll take it yeah yeah
um man and I was gonna say Okay carrying
on from that point I think
so we we've we've touched about the
inflated ego with girls but what it's
also done with guys is
it's taken away
that we we talked before about that
rejection right so now the way most guys
interact is it's it's all online right
it's all through the screen so you don't
need to develop
courage you don't need to develop social
skills and ability to talk in the same
way right you can just sit there and be
typing and swiping which is a very
different skill set to actually walking
up to a woman that you're interested in
and breaking the ice and trying to have
a conversation and so on and so I think
on both levels it's really really
skewing the situation yeah and also I
mean there's there's studies from some
of these dating apps showing something
that I mean women find what like 80 80
of men to be unattractive
I mean we only swipe right like it
depends what you look at but like like I
would say roughly five percent of the
time we swipe right on dating apps and
Men it's something like what 50 56
exactly yeah
yeah it's a
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and then I'm
like oh is she hot in there yeah it's
it's hard it's hard it's hard out there
and another thing that happens with men
is men are much more susceptible to the
Apex fallacy right which is that in in
terms of how we are rated and judged so
when people are even talking about men
or talking about dating and talking
about stuff oftentimes they're referring
to like 20 10 to 20 of the male
population the other 80 to 90 percent is
almost invisible right they're not even
being they're not even being considered
when I'm hearing certain conversations
about dating I'm like you guys are
talking about like a very very specific
set of go ahead even the girl yesterday
she's I was like you can't have
everything and she's like why not I'm
like I don't know because we're human
because these are people yeah and and
this is another challenge because of
course in this era we have you know
under the age of 30 in a lot of cities
in western countries women are actually
out earning men on average we know women
are getting the vast majority I think
about 65 of University degrees are going
to women now
um and as we know typically women tend
to date and mate across and up Social
SEO economically in terms of status and
so on so all of these things are
happening at the same time and it's
creating a very
I don't know man it's creating a weird
situation I asked because I as many of
you know I was just banned on Tick Tock
and we are demonetized on a daily basis
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible